there's light there was light at the end
of the tunnel that I wasn't aware of and
now it's here and I'm bathed in light
and man it feels good Kristoff st. John
star of The Young and the Restless dead
and 52 what exactly was it that you
started feeling sorry the actor played
Neil winters on the popular soap opera
since 1991 earning two Daytime Emmys
along the way this is unlike any other
medium or genre that we have this is a
soap where you live with us the audience
lives with us five days out of the week
every day 52 weeks a year there are no
reruns we're part of their family and so
that feels good the circumstances of his
death remain unconfirmed though the Los
Angeles Police Department tells et they
did respond to an incident on Sunday
which they're considering a possible
alcohol overdose the LAPD would not
confirm the name of the deceased finish
this sentence
I knew I was a soap star when when when
my daughter's dad you're competing
against all my cartoons st. John leaves
behind two daughters Paris and Lola st.
John his son Julian died of an apparent
suicide while in a mental health
facility back in 2014 we are getting
through it
survival was very difficult obviously
towards the end of the year I miss you
greatly son and it's it's a tough
it's a tough time Christoph's last week
before his death was a response to a
post that read quote grieving the loss
of a child is a process it begins on the
day your child passes and ends the day
the parent joins them he replied never a
truer word was spoken that call was the
worst call I've ever had mama I knew I
knew that I knew that because it's every
it's every parent's nightmare too when
when she's my ex-wife and I knew what I
heard her scream screaming that he had
died I knew Christophe and his ex-wife
amia became advocates for mental health
and suicide prevention after Julian's
death opening up about their son to ET
in 2015 I see my boy from way back I
don't see the the kid who went through a
very rough time with drugs and alcohol
and schizophrenia I see the child and I
raised he's a handsome young man he was
a good son he's a great son he's a good
brother he could have been a good
husband to someone if he had been given
that chance my son wanted to live he was
just confused about how to live
[Music]
you